As part of our experts in
emotion interview series.
We have the honor of speaking
with doctor John Kasey, Opo. Um,
he's going to speaking to
us about psychophysiology,
both the scope of psychophysiology and
the promise it bears for emotion research.
So Dr Casio Opo uses a
variety of psychophysiological
methods in his research,
including Autonomic
Neuroendocrin, Fmri, EEG,
Erp, as well as quantitative genetics. Um,
Doctor Casio Opo is the Tiffany and
Margaret Blake distinguished service
professor at the University of Chicago.
He's the director of the University of
Chicago Center for cognitive and social
neuroscience and the founding director
of the initiative of the office of the
vice president for research and national
laboratories at the University of
Chicago, seen as a pioneer in
the field of social neuroscience.
He's won numerous awards.
These include the scientific impact
award from the Society for Experimental
Social Psychology,
a merit award from the National Institute
of Health and a presidential citation
from the American
psychological association,
the Theoretical Innovation Prize from
the Society for personality and Social
Psychology, the Isi highly cited,
researchers and psychiatry and psychology,
the distinguished scientific contribution
award from the American Psychological
Association.
The award for distinguished scientific
contributions to psychophysiology from
the psych of society for
psychophysiological research
and the troll and research
award from the National
Academy of Sciences.
Dr Cassiopeia is also been
elected president of several
scientific organizations
that include the association
for Psychological Science,
the Society for personality
and Social Psychology,
the society for psychophysiological
research and the Society for social
neuroscience.
Doctor Cassiopeia was a past editor
of the journal Psychophysiology,
a former associate editor,
a psychological review and perspectives
on psychological science and it's
currently in an an associate
editor of social neuroscience.
So I'm very honored to now turn to our
experts and emotion interview with Doctor
John Kasey. Yotpo. Welcome John.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Okay.
That's what I thought we might get started
with is asking you a bit about sort
of what first got you
interested in this field,
sort of worded things first begin for you
the assumption that most
rational abrogate luck or economists
aren't interested in predicting individual
behavior. They're interested
in predicting the notion.
Boston humans aren't completely rational.
You just a little rational,
but they're randomly irrational when
you some across individuals to a society
level,
you get pure rationality.
But I knew that I was
systematically irrational.
That made me interested in emotions are
and in biological proxies that might be
underlying those emotions.
And so that led me from economics
to graduate school in Psychology.
And so I've been interested since I was
700 graduate basically because of the
misinformed assumptions
underlying economics.
Excellent. So irrationality drew
you towards studying emotions,
you an irrational act. But uh,
but one that I'm happy with.
So I'd love to move on to ask you some
questions about your research now.
So I mean you are widely known for really,
you know,
playing this pivotal role in founding
the field of social neuroscience,
which is devoted to trying to understand
social processes, including emotion,
you know, through the lens of
these different physiological
tools. And you know,
as the pioneer of this field,
I wonder what you see as some of the most
exciting discoveries that have emerged
from social neuroscience.
Science is a,
a really interesting and unique
perspective to them and it's always,
it's always struck me that we're
fundamentally social animals and we're
fundamentally biologic class.
And when I first started
working in the field,
social and biological perspectives
were actually quite divided.
Uh,
my phd mentor friends,
instead of be persistent on
pursuing this biological approach,
I won't help you get a job.
It was active antagonists and the
neuroscience courses I was in at lab,
I worked in [inaudible] for social
factors were irrelevant because there were
recent evolutionary developments.
They on real basic implication for
structural function, even if they were,
they were too complicated to
understand, so not worth studying. Uh,
and it,
it just seemed obvious that the
comprehensive explanation is required both
perspectives and they required both
perspectives because behavior emotions are
complicated. By complicated, I mean
that they have multiple causes.
I might eat because I'm hungry.
Biologic cost I might eat because Uri,
because people around me are eating
or be conscious of the time of day,
more social costs. Oh, cultural causes.
And so if we're going to have come
up with comprehensive explanations,
we can't rule out half of the
causes is irrelevant. And so that,
that was something that attracted me
early. And of course we're all Mona's,
we're all the terminus
and Mona says scientists.
So if we're going to understand these
processes are an important avenue for
understanding these psychological
and social processes,
do you see is through the material based
through which they express themselves
and clearly work on emotion system as
advanced because we paid attention the
biological mechanisms which
emotions are expressed?
Oh, I couldn't agree
more with you. I mean,
I think some of the most
fundamental discoveries especially,
you know in the past decade has been
through understanding biological,
like you're saying
processes and mechanisms.
One of the, uh, yesterday dances,
one of the interesting advances are it's
just how important simple connections
are.
We,
we started looking at social isolation
because when we first used the term
social neuroscience 20 years ago, um, I,
in the very first draft of the
manuscript in which I wrote that term,
I put the term and I put a color man,
put an oxymoron question mark because
I knew that my neuroscience colleagues
would say these two terms just
don't fit together. But in fact,
social organisms, social species, by
definition, creates support. I mean,
there's four structures.
Those structures evolve because
they help those individuals survive,
reproduce,
and care for their offspring long enough.
But they have a genetic legacy and those
structures have genetic say that our
neural hormonal mechanisms
that support that.
So we'll work on prefontal cortex or
on a mid to lower on oxytocin or all
samples of biological or targets that
we've now found to be instrumental in
construction or maintenance
of these sorts of factors.
If you look at any social
mammal human down to in Burger,
it's Blackburn's in fruit flies,
any social animal of its isolated,
they die at earlier when isolated them,
when they're allowed to live in the group.
So there's something really interesting
going on about those connections we just
take for granted because we
live in that if you will,
global environment as part
of our everyday exist.
So it seems invisible because
it's unchanging from our
perspective. And I mean,
yeah,
big part of your work that you were
just talking about is really, you know,
looking at the role that things like
loneliness or social isolation can impact
and, and play on our physiological
responses. And I just wondered, you know,
what you think and your work has spoken
to if the implications this might have
for both our physical
and mental wellbeing.
Well,
we've actually been doing longitudinal
research and experiments to examine that
when we're looking at short term effects,
like whether it makes you sad.
We do experiments and indeed if I
make you feel isolated you get sadder.
But we've also looked
longitudinally using cross panels,
fretful equation models to rule
out alternative interpretations.
And what we find is when you, uh,
for whatever reason become only your,
over time you actually become more
depressed as a result of a feeling lonely.
We've ruled out social sport,
our objective stressors
or perceived stressors or
hostility or a number of other
alternative interpretations
for that effect.
So it really looks like
the lonelier you get,
the more depressed you're likely
to get your at risk for that.
And the other direction.
Being depressed doesn't necessarily
impact a tendency for you to become an on
there. It seems to be driven by
loneliness making you more depressed.
Interesting. And I know you've also
done some work showing that it uh,
loneliness also impacts just
some of our most basic, you know,
physical health functioning.
We've shown everything unless you show
higher levels of cortisol in the morning
and then you show ladder diurnal
cycles of cortisol, the stress hormone.
And that's the case both when we
look across p Oh and when we look
longitudinally, but then a person
looking at the same cross legs,
Russia equation modeling approach.
As I mentioned,
we're looking at depression the moment
that seems to also increase if you both a
height limit, but Twitter, adrenal
cortical access, it's very stress system.
Interestingly, it doesn't affect
the stress systems writ large.
We don't get increased
sympathetic activity,
generally we don't get increased catechol
and one or JV sympathetic Katrina
mentioned already activity.
It's really seemed to be of
us favor in the HPA axis.
So that's something that's
not exactly a stress response,
but a more specific if you will,
metabolic response to the dangers of
finding yourself as a member of a social
species.
But in an isolated context
mean what's really fascinating here
is you've established all these robust
affects, you know, looking
at loneliness for example,
and its impact on different physiological
parameters that relate to our mental
and physical health wellbeing.
And at this point, I mean,
I feel like social neuroscience has just
grown and blossomed as a really strong
field. What do you see moving forward is
some of the biggest challenges it faces?
Okay.
Uh, it's a great time to be a
social neuroscientist. They,
what we've seen him at the last couple
of decades is that a real gravitation to
more important question sees
these complicated questions.
Both of us social scientists
and neuroscientists
required either just a very
molecular analysis. By
molecular, I mean in,
in the neuroscience side,
literally a molecular approach.
And the social science,
I mean, uh, an isolated approach.
And that we would only consider the
situational factors because those were
something we can do something about.
Now we're understanding that you
fully understand how situations impact
individuals.
We need to understand something about
the brains of those individuals and how
those brains are collectively
influencing one another.
And so this social neuroscience
approaches being used globally, um, we've,
we traveled a good bit. We
have collaborations and Latin
American nation, Europe,
and we see this approach really big,
used to take on a number of social
problems around the world. And so I,
there isn't a interesting question
that's being asked that was social
neuroscience approach might tell us
something about all of the global problems
that we're facing. A fundamental a
here left and all the social problems.
And so it's being used increasingly to
try to improve the world we live in,
in the coming decades.
So it sounds like right now for those
who may be interested in embarking and
social neuroscience, it's just
this burgeoning time get on board.
That's right.
Like interesting and complex questions.
It's definitely be approached to consider.
Okay.
I mean, in speaking of complexity,
I mean your work, you know,
has impressively drawn from this diverse
range of physiological parameters
ranging from Fmr, I. E, g,
e r p neuroendocrine response
and quantitative genetics,
and taking this really impressive
kind of multimodal approach.
What do you see at this point is some
of the most effective tools in your own
work for studying emotion per se?
I, the breeding the chick is clearly a,
a development that gives us great, uh,
a greater grip on what
I'm bringing processes,
response to these social
structures and social challenges.
And so we're doing more of it that
we're increasingly using both electrical
neuroimaging procedures that give you
spatial and temporal information and,
and the functional brain
imaging metabolic procedures,
but the quantitative genetics,
the epigenetics is really quite exciting
and it's something that we showed a
couple of years ago.
Then they feeling isolated,
connect to affect which
genes are turned on and off.
We've replicated and extended
that finding and, and in fact,
contrary to what most thought 40,
50 years ago,
it's the oldest cells that are active
in modulating the social environment.
I in a way that makes perfect sense.
Bacteria were the first, uh, uh,
pathogens on the immune system,
a mock balled the oldest
cells that community a ball
to protect against bacteria
and is in fact those cells that are most
sensitive to your social environment
changes in the social environment.
So these genes are being turned on
off to help protect you against, uh,
the differences in packages to which
you're likely to be exposed if you're
around others and an half
I'm social circumstances or
if you're around others in
a hostel social circumstance.
That's really fascinating.
I mean, so you know,
you think about all these complex tools
and the ones that are likely to bear
some of the most fascinating implications
right now for understanding social
processes. What do you see
as some of the sort of, um,
kind of next critical a methodological
next steps in this field?
What are the tools that we
need but we don't yet have?
I think it's really the perspective
going down from the molecular to the
cultural, all those levels together.
And those, those titles are large,
the computational tools.
And so for instance,
one of the things in which we're working
is with the high performance computing
when you used to be called
supercomputing center.
So then we're able to bring more
computational power to looking at these
mechanisms both within most of
organization but also understanding the
mechanisms linking across
the levels of organization.
That's partly what I
think is important and uh,
we'll be real opportunities in the future.
A second,
interestingly enough is
conceptual philosophical.
There are simply, um, philosophical,
um,
obstacles still to how we're
making progress on a brain
image can be incredibly
compelling in terms of its appearance.
But it's fundamentally correlation.
And there had been far too many
conclusions drawn policies,
established publications and high profile
science journals because the images
appeared to be so compelling rather
than the logic experimental design.
And so there's,
there's work in that domain about how
do we go about making these translations
of specific mechanisms
across lots of organization.
And that in part is greater
computational part. And part,
how are we using that computational power
to gain the greatest leverage on the
questions that are being asked.
So we also working with some philosophers
of science on just basic inferential
structure underlying this
kind of scientific approach.
It's fascinating.
I mean when you think about then where
sort of the face of the future's headed
when we think about social neuroscience
and how it can inform emotion.
You've already talked about a lot of
really important steps of looking across
multiple levels of bringing in people
from different disciplines like you know,
philosophers of science to sort of have
them bring their own sort of analytic
tools to bear. Where do you see
them, the face of the future headed?
Is this where we're going?
Oh, that's great question.
When I started, yeah,
I did research and
built my own electrodes.
We did everything ourselves in
our laboratories. That period,
uh, is a little bit like when we
think about yesterday, you're,
it's kind of a fun memory, but it's not
something that we're likely to return to.
The question seven are not being asked
are sufficiently complicated and they go
across enough disciplinary fields that
increasingly we're seeing scientific
teams very much like when
I was just describing.
So the study of motion in it's full
of flavor requires a lot of different
perspectives,
a lot of different disciplinary expertise
and no single individual can have the
kind of expertise that's necessary
across all those disciplines.
So increasingly what I see or scientific
teams coming together that are
interdisciplinary in
nature and the duck tab,
a leader and everybody else's,
the follower,
if you and I represent to dis the men,
are you catching her teeth?
And we're going to work in a synergistic
fashion. I can't be the leader.
You're the follower. We both are
going to argue. We're both bands,
the intersection and
our parent disciplines.
And in so doing we're going to transform
out. Each of us think about the problem.
And so I think are also mean ass,
um,
administrators as grant funding agencies
and entities think about scientific
awards. We need to stop
asking for who's the leader,
who's the author of this publication,
but rather to what extent was it a
synergistic output of a collective group?
To what extent was everybody a leader?
Is everybody responsible?
If you and I are producing more than
a hundred percent that's perfectly
plausible through synergist and stuff.
Neither one can take credit for even their
portion because it's a product of the
interaction and that's something I think
that we need to try to build in those
sites to be teams and we need trying
to try to reward the next generation of
scientists aren't faced
with the obstacles.
That partly just one big evaluated
for tenure and promotions.
I mean,
I couldn't agree more and I think really
thinking more about the collective as
you're saying as opposed
to the individual.
I mean that's going to make
better science altogether.
That's right.
It allows us to ask these more complicated
questions and very sophisticated
fashion rather than pretending that we
act to have all the expertise needed or
Archie the question in a way that we
can answer it, but calling it the whole,
when we're only looking at a
very small passionate problem.
So then when you think about,
you know,
students who are going to
be a big part of, you know,
making the future of the field,
you know,
as it moves forward and you have
students come to you asking for advice,
you know, they're thinking
about embarking in this field.
What kind of advice do you
typically give students?
Well,
the common core
and the answer I give is becoming
an expert in a dish. And first,
I mean I don't think students understand
that will spend 40 to 50 years.
I have four, five, six
years for Grad School,
maybe of York two on post doc, then six
years for tenure and then my career set,
they're still very, very early.
It's Brown, all of that very,
very early in their career. And
as you both know, as a faculty,
you never stop learning. As a scientist,
you're always learning something new.
And so you can't contribute meaningfully
to an interdisciplinary team if you
have no disciplinary expertise.
So it's to learn the discipline well,
but recognize the importance of
related disciplines. You know, we can,
sonics is a collective effort.
It's not a solitary inch across.
I think we really need to appreciate if
we can work and talk to other scientists,
they can be your best tutors. You can
be their students, they're your student.
And together over time you
acquire more and more expertise,
but you don't use syrup the experts
in a privileged position within that
collective team. And I think
that's, that's the way to
become interdisciplinary.
It's an awareness of its importance,
a humble nuts about what you know and
what you can know and a willingness to
learn from others.
Well thank you so much. This was a
great opportunity to speak with you.
And I think that's some of the best
advice a student could have, you know,
sort of recognizing their own role that
they can play, but seeing themselves as,
you know, sort of in a very humbling
way, part of a bigger mission and group.
Thank you. It's been a real
pleasure. Thank you so much.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor John Cassiopeia
from the University of Chicago. Thanks
again for speaking today. Thank you.